hi everyone it's Jerry I have a round
three game to share with you from the
2022 World Blitz Jess championship
on the white end Ivan chaparinov and
he's playing against Magnus Carlson
there's one main takeaway for me from
this one and it comes out of the opening
a move an idea Carlson goes with I
wasn't too familiar with it
out of this closed Catalan
there's also
and end game plan Carlson implements you
may find instructive
overall it's a very high quality game by
both sides and it's not until the late
stage of the end game and when
chaparinov is living off of the
increment where there's a blender
now it's as early as this move six
where Carlson expands on the queen side
only after things are cool on the king's
side he's completed development there
is one square I want to draw your
attention to out of this opening it's C4
this is a sensitive Square sensitive why
well there's not a convenient recapturer
of that point the bishop is now on the
long diagonal
what does this mean well in many lines
black can actually go ahead and capture
on C4 who's going to be the one to
recapture
it's now going to be down to one of the
knights or the queen
okay
the A5 move is however indirect having
an influence on C4
black has an eye on maybe going further
with A4
this could maybe have some cramping
effect some domino effect
on the entire Queen side if this is
allowed it's not allowed in this game
Knight C3 is played
healthy Square for the night it watches
over this Pawn advance
to illustrate
if you're not playing let's say Knight
to C3 if you continued with let's say B3
A4 could still be played do you want to
take as as white away from the center
C4 would be that much more weak the
queen side pawns would
basically I'll be weak do you want to
maintain your structure
develop the bishop prepare to meet a b
with a B black may just go one step
further
eight moves in do you really want to
deal with this Pawn this deep in your
house is white this may even set the
stage for a night to be planted on B4
a piece that is not easily extracted
applying pressure to A2 tying down a
rook you get the idea this one Pawn can
be a menace to the entire White Queen
side
it stopped cold on this move seven with
Knight C3
and at the same time we might say that
C4 is now all the more sensitive because
this guy can no longer control that
square
in many lines out of the Catalan it'll
go to D2
watching over that point as well as
supporting an E4 break additionally from
D2 it stays out of the Queen's way when
she's on C2
to watch over C4 directly
okay in the game Knight C3
black green forces his strongest Pawn
B3 only now
B6
Bishop B2
and where to go
with the Queen Bishop
Asics where it puts pressure on the most
sensitive Square
Pop Quiz as white
what would be your reaction to Black's
last move
feel free to pause the video
okay
move played in the game
Queen D3
it's not considered best
considered best is
this underdeveloping
Knight to D2 unleashing the bishop
maintaining this tension
if in this position you
thought to yourself well just capture
notice what is happening if you go for
this capture
black is recapturing and has gained
something
what is that something well if we look
at the structure right now this is the
one area where white is stronger
in comparing the C pawns this is a pawn
of Rank 4 versus a pawn of rank 3 and
they are being exchanged and in the
process a new square is opening up
for Black's Queen Knight
okay best in this case would be to
maintain the tension
white goes with Queen to D3
and this next move is the one
takeaway the main takeaway for me from
this game Carlson's next move is B5 a
very temporary
Pawn sacrifice
play follows with C takes B
C takes B this is going to lead to
Mass exchanges we
kind of from this point on end up fast
forwarding through
the middle game and we get down to
a very simplified end game in short
order
white picks up the pawn and is now in
this
in a pickle in a pin
and in just a few moves the pawn will be
one back
I'd like to point out
why maybe this Knight d2 move is a
better choice
um you'll know after Queen D3 and B5
white doesn't have the option in this
position to grab space on the queen side
with C5 because B4 would hit and you
could already resign
black will be winning material
however if C4 was defended with the
Knight B5 could be met with C5
it's a totally different structure
okay it's a new option for white
the C5 move with the Knight on D2 rather
than having the queen on D3
in this game Queen D3
B5 Chop Chop Knight takes on B5 and
we get on with development immediately
making use of this newly opened C6
Square
from here A4 Queen B6
just piling up ready to get this Pawn
back soon
taking advantage of the pinned 95 Knight
E7
and here come the mass exchanges night
for night Bishop takes Pawn
a b pawns exchanged Queen Rooks
exchanged
Queens exchanged
and we get into this ending
where it's even going to simplify a
little bit more soon
Bishop C2
and Rook to B7 I thought when I
initially skimmed through this game I
was wondering what are you doing exactly
if Rook C1 he get out of that pin by
flicking in
Bishop to A3 real quick if you wanted to
okay it's not really a big deal
it's one way out
Rook B7 in this game Bishop takes Knight
white has the bishop pair
but all pawns are on the same flank so
this Knight is
you know he's he's ready to
yeah the mobility of the Knight is not
in question he doesn't have to go all
the way to the queen side there's no
reason to go there so perfectly content
just
sticking around on the king side and
after this last move
he's now exerting some pressure on E5
this is already a
sort of uh an important moment in the
game
not it's not critical but I think
if White had made a different decision
on this move 27
he would probably find it a little bit
easier to play this ending
so I'll throw this one too as a pop quiz
what would be your way to
react to Black's move how would you
how would you react to the threat Knight
takes Pawn feel free to pause the video
okay move played in the game is F4
it's still considered an equalish
position but
you'll notice with F4 this Knight now
has a new Square could already think
about jumping to
computer points out that best is to
defend with the bishop
making use of the fact that the bishop
is poison
because of back rank mate
so white could have played this defended
the pawn and
after maybe a flight Square just backed
off
and the bishop would be a very
convenient defender of E5 and also watch
out for even
The Rook C1 moves down the line
okay Bishop C3 not played F4 instead
again
this Knight is now a little jumpy has
that E3 Square
from here we have the flight Square
Bishop F3
Bishop F5
and now white makes the decision to
exchange another set of miners Bishop
takes Knight
Pawn takes bishop and we enter this
opposite color Bishop ending
now why go for this capture well I think
it's related to the Knight
being a jumpy piece it has that E3
square right around the corner there
might be Rook to C1 you're in a pin if
you go over to defend there's maybe
Knight to H2 winning a pawn or maybe
Landing some Fork
maybe both
white doesn't want to deal with it
knocks out the night Pawn takes how to
win this position
okay let's see Carlson's approach in
this opposite color Bishop position
first activating the king along the
light squares this is a two row two
result position for black
why is black in the driver's seat in
this one
well
what grabs my attention about this one
is this configuration considering the a
pawn excuse me the H Pawn and the g
pawns it's this one Pawn here that is
holding up two white Pawns
and also black has a successful Pawn
break
with G or excuse me with F6 increasing
the pressure on the E5 point
first he's improving the king as best he
can
and now with this pressure here
comes F6 you'll also note
that this bishop is basically pinned to
the first rank
if it's ever moving for example
in this position right here if it takes
a step now this Rook could slide over
and this Pawn is soon to be one we have
G2 covered no defending it
so it's a very passive position still
holdable but very difficult especially
as the clock is
you know not soon to not be on white
side
Here Comes F6
e takes f g takes F and slowly what is
happening
a past Pawn is being created or at least
it's narrowing down now to a two to one
majority in the center
for black
from here ideally
well for starters you definitely want to
avoid a rook exchange if you're going to
try and win this
having it stripped to opposite color
Bishops specific
it's almost certainly going to be a draw
so gotta keep the Rooks on
and how exactly to position your Pawns
in this ending
in a way so that it tries to limit the
dark Square Bishop you don't want you
want to try and stay strong as black on
the dark squares your Bishop has the
light let the pawns control the dark
and soon in this time pressure this is
where we have a mistake by white
on this move 48. hands up dropping the
bishop back
time pressure gets the best of everybody
it's kind of
I don't know a little a little bit odd I
guess you didn't see this next idea by
Carlson which is to uh plant the King on
a secure Square
he could have continued checking The
King and I don't know exactly where the
king
would go where you know it can no longer
be checked so best is Rook to Da to just
keep checking
and it's going to be really irritating
you could even still think about keeping
the bishop around on B4 to bother the
base Point E5
but it ends up going to this very
passive Square
E1
and from here we have the idea Bishop F5
see where the king is going this is a
perfect pocket for the king there will
be no checks and now it's all about
targeting E4 and there's really nothing
what I could do about it
so what is try to check
at this point the king is ideal The Rook
is ideal the Pawns
you know they shouldn't go anywhere
and it's just about repositioning the
bishop you want to get it on this
diagonal
how to get it there first Bishop D7
this is cut out he tries to get here
that's cut out but
now there's no cutting out this move
it's defended and soon we're going to
have the coordination on E2
and just like that the position
collapses white resigns this Pawn now
will fall
white took a in this ending a little bit
too
yeah he was a little bit too passive in
time pressure I guess we might say
dropping the bishop back like that E2
will now fall
there's no real
try now for white if here's one of the
many ways this game could continue if
there wasn't resignation
computers even suggesting just go to G2
something like this the bishop could go
here maybe the Rook is scared away
maybe this Rook comes back here Pawn
runs
could always give these checks could
even consider improving the king in this
specific case without fear of this check
because The Bishop's watching over that
square this is one of the many ways
black hood maybe have made progress if
the game continued a lot of ways to do
it when this Pawn is gone and you're
working with two connected past Pawns
anyhow let's have a look at
the tail the tape on this one we could
see just how accurate the game was
um that was the big
shift
in the evaluation that end game not a
big shift but giving up the bishop for
Knight going into the opposite color
Bishop bending if we go back to this
point right here after Bishop to A6
it's that reaction Queen D3 rather than
Knight to D2
a very technical point right out of the
opening but that's where there's this
however slight some dip it's even from
that point and
you know only until the late stage did
we have the blender with the bishop
going to E1 assuming that very uh
passive post
in the end we have a handful of any
accuracies one mistake for a chaparinov
and
pretty squeaky clean for Carlson there
97 percent
accuracy after
all is said and done
anyhow Feel Free as usual to leave any
feedback to this video in the comments
section below hope you enjoyed it and
maybe took a thing or two away
that's all for now take care bye